all right uh we're getting more horrific
scenes of violence out of democratic-led
cities and a white house that refuses to
deal with the reality here's an example
you have a 33 year old woman who was
heading to work at New York's JFK
Airport she's establishly beaten so
badly by a homeless man that among her
many ailments she has not been able
she's not able to see out of her eye and
she might lose it this 41 year olds what
he'd Foster is facing felony assault
charges and you probably guessed by now
his rap sheet is long seven priors
including assaulting another woman with
a screwdriver a conviction for murdering
his 82 year old foster grandmother in a
brutal beating how's this guy even out
of prison when he was 14 he was out on
probation when he committed this latest
attack now over in Philadelphia we're
getting disturbing surveillance footage
of the murder of a Temple University
grad police say the 23 year old Everett
Beauregard was the victim of an
unprovoked murder when he was shot and
killed while walking home with all that
in mind listen to what the White House
had to say about whether our cities are
safe or not
Mr President Biden think America's big
cities are safe can you say more well we
know that deaths and robberies are up
about 20 in the first half of this year
so I'm wondering if he thinks America's
big cities are safe so I'll say this um
that same story also uh stated that the
crime is complicated and multifaceted so
I guess
if I think America's big cities are safe
it is not it is not a um
it is not a yes or no question it is
very much a question of what has he done
fascinating response Dana have you ever
said to yourself I need to hear more
from a question
um well maybe I mean you get a little
time to figure out like where you want
to go
it's it's news everywhere so that answer
should be automatic and her the answer
from the White House is not matching the
mood of the public so you have to read
the room they are not reading the room
because
um okay you could maybe make a case it's
multifaceted in certain places but
people are seeing this every single day
and if you're in any sort of briefing at
the White House on the political
situation that they're in going into the
midterms you see that crime is right
below inflation and economy which you
could combine as one of the major issues
and you add border to that which people
equate also with crime then you have a
serious Law Enforcement issue I thought
it was very interesting that Jen sake is
now she's out of the White House she's a
commentator on MSNBC she's asked about
it and she said yeah crime's a big deal
it's going to hurt the Democrats right
and so if you don't have an answer for
that and you know she could have turned
around and said what did the president
just sign this bill there are things
that they could say I'm not going to try
to do their jobs for them but I do think
that the feeling in the country is
unease and anxiety about crime and that
is a that is a government's number one
responsibility is protect the public and
if people don't feel like that's
happening they will get responded to at
The Ballot Box Jesse what I'm fascinated
by is they keep saying Republicans are
making the most of this crime excuse me
they're not even making the most of the
crime we've seen the video I don't see
any 30-second spot I'm not seeing any
highlights I'm watching surveillance
video and Republicans are sitting there
saying don't blame us and they're right
they never said to fund the police they
never said let's go hey let's have
prosecutors go easy on criminals yeah
it's it's impossible to ignore the crime
wave when you talk about climate change
okay you can't really feel it the crime
it's in your face and this is how I
would answer the question if I was
Corrine John Pierre
from France I would say this for the
most part American cities are safe and
that's why you Peter and everybody in
this room and millions of Americans
across the country live in these cities
they work in these cities they raise
kids in these cities and some of you go
out late at night and party in these
cities but in certain neighborhoods in
these cities there is a surge in crime
and this is what we're doing about it X
Y and Z that's it now if I can do a
better job of being a press secretary
then then she can what is she doing up
there because I'm not even a Democrat
and it's that easy and when you see
someone
Pummel a woman like a caveman and it's
not the first time we've been watching
horrific things shatter her eye socket
at JFK where's AOC where's Kathy hokel
the woman running for governor here
where is now the National Organization
of Women where's the metoo movement I
mean a woman got groped and you'd see a
press conference this woman is getting
her face busted up at JFK you know JFK
you can't fly into JFK without being
vaxxed but you can smash a woman's faces
way out on the way out and no one no one
says Sharpton hasn't said anything they
talk about right-wing violence but you
look at this on the television every day
sure what's your impression okay there's
not enough police we know that we know
that in major cities when you call the
police it could take anything from 20
minutes to five hours especially New
Orleans no New Orleans Washington
Chicago Los Angeles today my grand
children went to school and in the line
before they dropped off there was a
homeless man there with a shirt of
hacking at his chest there was blood
going everywhere the little kids were
screaming it took 20 minutes for the
police to come and which I'm talking
about
from kindergarten to eighth grade right
over the road from the school is a
homeless encampment right over the road
and there's been 11 complaints the
police do nothing but there's not enough
of them there's too much crime for the
police to deal with judge I want you to
weigh in on whatever you want to say
Obviously but I just want to also keep
this in mind a lot of people are saying
to fund the police are victims uh think
about the mayor uh the winners run for
mayor over in Los Angeles she had her
house robbed and her gun taken then you
have this uh state senator Kimberly
light lightford and U.S rep Mary gay
Scanlon who came out to defund the
police and reimagine policing they were
both carjacked within 90 minutes of each
other Bill Walton six foot eleven big
redhead who's got all for defunting the
police and for black lives matter Madame
he's a good guy but he is now
complaining to the mayor of San Diego
saying I can't ride my bike without
being chased down by homeless people who
are trying to chase me down and steal
the bike from a 611 uh Bill Walton so
what do you say about this because
people don't want to believe that crime
will affect them and they distance
themselves by saying it'll never happen
to me the victim must have done
something wrong and therefore I'm fine
and you can defund the police and all of
a sudden when they become victims they
Now understand that this is pervasive
let me tell you something she couldn't
possibly answer the question Kareem
Jean-Pierre because to do so and to do
so honestly would be to indict her boss
and the whole Administration murders are
up 30 percent in the last two years in
this country and the bottom line is this
nonsense it's complicated and
multifaceted crime is not complicated
and multifaceted crime is simple and
it's one-dimensional you got a criminal
and you got a victim I don't give a darn
what happened to the criminal in his
life in the past the only thing I care
about is what he's doing today and what
they want to make it complicated so that
we all feel stupid and say G me we don't
really know about it but let me tell you
what they're doing they're denying the
trauma that the victims are going
through they are not giving the victims
a voice and they are protecting the
Criminal by creating bail laws that
allow them to go out reoffend embolden
them no consequences and I'll go one
better because I've sat in these
courtrooms I've prosecuted cases they
create rules of evidence that make it
impossible for us to know what the truth
is evidence is being hidden all the time
in criminal courtrooms this woman is
savagely beaten coming out of JFK are
you kidding me you know what she did
wrong nothing no she's happened this guy
walked up to and started coming on to
her he didn't want anything to do with
it next you know she gets beaten
senseless and that happens all the time
right judge yes all the time there's
Randomness that's the most dangerous
part of all of this everybody thinks
well you know it's domestic violence he
knew her she knew that she gave each
other the eye no you're getting shot in
the head from behind by someone you
don't even know you know you're getting
cards soccer punched yep sucker punched
and you know what the administration
here in New York takes a sucker punch
from an attempted murder with a guy with
a busted uh uh brain bleed Buzz
fractured skull and a fractured orbital
bone from attempted murder to a
misdemeanor unbelievable but two people
follow you home now in Los Angeles and
they're not in crack cars they're in
great cause so you look in your rear
view many times there's no problem and
then as soon as you get home they rub
and shoot you sadly Sharon for anything
to change has got to happen to rich
people uh and that's when people realize
it's not gang against gang that's when
it's happening in Chicago now but it
happens it happens in Beverly Hills
every day that's what I'm saying yeah
hey Sean to hear Hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else